février une nvelle année venait juste de
commencer et le joueur du grenier se
disait qu'il était temps de choisir son
prochain
test Ilou danso et les
jeux plus vite sou il trou ce qu'il
cherch
pasme pas
jeit
[Musique]
çaordac Norte quoi il s'asseya sur le
canapé et commença à jouer au jeu il se
régalait il avait enfin trouvé le sujet
du prochain test mais peut-être que
plutôt que jouer aurait-il mieux valu
qu'il s'occupe des voies qu'il a dans sa
tête des voies comme la mienne
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 salut tout le monde Pac-Man tout le
monde connaît Pac-Man he et c'est très
certainement avec Mario et Sonic la
figure du jeu vidéo la plus
reconnaissable habituellement quand on
vous dit Pac-Man et je pense qu'on est
tous d'accord sur le fait que tout le
monde pense à ça un principe simple
Pac-Man se déplace dans un labyrinthe et
doit manger des packgom alors qu'il est
poursuivi par des fantômes sur son
chemin il trouvera aussi des super
packgum qui lui permettront à son tour
de manger les ennemis et c'est paradoxal
parce que autant je suis sûr que vous
connaissez tous Pac-Man autant je pense
que la plupart d'entre vous n'y ont
jamais joué d'ailleurs le jeu à la base
s'appelait puckman mais a été ensuite
changé en Pac-Man pour le marché
occidental afin de éviter que des petits
malins ne transformment les bords
d'arcade en fuckman très vite devant le
succès du premier jeu les développeurs
ont évidemment voulu faire des suites
c'est comme ça qu'on a eu par exemple
Miss Pac-Man alors le jeu était un peu
différent he quatre niveaux au lieu d'un
mais bon pour créer le personnage ils
ont pas dû se fouler il faut trouver une
idée un nouveau personnage je sais pas
ne bougez pas
vous et ça s'est pas arrêté là puisque
derrière on a eu toute la famille Pacman
junior baby Pacman et cetera ne bougez
pas vous avez pensé à quelque chose Marc
rapidement le jeu a été adapté sur
console avec par exemple Pacman sur
Atari 2600 qui est réputé comme étant
une des plus mauvaises versions la
question c'est comment on peut rater un
jeu aussi simple je veux dire regardez
les fantômes qui clignotent là c'est
dans le jeu c'est pas un bug de capture
ou d'émulation c'est vraiment comme ça
dans le jeu bon est-ce que vous avez
déjà vu un fantôme pouvez m'affirmer que
ça clignote
pas
davidû faut voir que la télévision à
l'époque était inondée de pub de jeu
avec des gens qui ont l'air de s'amuser
comme des ouf parce que tu vas pas me
faire croire que quiconque joue à Pacman
comme ça c'est parce que j'ai super
envie de chier enfin bref il y avait des
pubs partout mais les tr/4 des jeux àari
c'était des merdes bugger jusqu'au cul
et les éditeurs n'en avaient rien à CER
donc pour revenir au jeux c'est pareil
pour les couleurs des fantômes sur
l'arcade les fantômes étaient clairement
de couleurs différentes ici ils sont
presque tous de la même couleur
c'està-dire pastel dégueulasse
clignotant et pour le reste sérieusement
vous allez pas me dire que la tarie ne
pouvait pas faire tourner le sprite de
Pac-Man dans la direction où il regarde
pouvait pas faire des ronds pour les
gommes
pouvez pas faire des fruits non ben ça
c'est un fruit là d'ailleurs Pacman sur
Atar 2600 a été si mauvais qu'il a été
une des grandes causes avec le jeu it de
la perte de confiance des acheteurs et
du Grand crack des jeux vidéos de 1983
qui a presque fait disparaître le jeu
vidéo ça va c'est qu'un fruit qu'est-ce
qu'on
[Musique]
risque David
C9 alors la liste des jeux Pac-Man est
affreusement longue pour vous parler de
tous he parce qu'il y a eu énormément de
jeux au fil des années pour essayer de
moderniser la licence il a eu ses puzzle
game ses jeux de plateforme ses jeux de
course c'est Pary game et dans la
plupart des cas c'est rarement des jeux
horribles mais c'est juste des jeux mais
au passage la licence s diversifiée
puisqu'il a même eu son dessin animé
avec le générique bien connu de William
lemergy comme un ballon et citron c'est
pacmanac le jeu dont on va parler
maintenant a d'ailleurs été inspiré du
design du cartoon Pac-Man car dans la
tentative désespérée d'innover un des
jeux les plus étranges du monde a vu le
jour c'est Pacman 2 the new adventure
qui n'est pas la suite de pacman 1 the
new adventure parce que ce jeu n'existe
pas c'est donc la suite de ça e si tu
regardes bien il y a non alors ce jeu
n'est pas décrit comme un jeu vidéo mais
plutôt comme une espèce de cartoon
interactif on y contrôle pas Pacman à
proprement parler on peut juste orienter
sa vue et sa direction en gros vous lui
dites va à gauche et il va à gauche mais
il avance tout seul la deuxième commande
du jeu sert à orienter sa vue pour lui
faire remarquer des objets ou des pièges
par exemple je veux dire si vous voulez
que Pac-Man remarque la lettre au sol il
faut lui pointer le sol sinon il va
rester comme un con devant où sont les
clés que j'ai fait tomber par terre et
se sont probablement envolé le premier
niveau a un objectif assez simple Miss
Pacman vous demande d'aller chercher du
lait pour bébé Pacman et pour ça vous
allez devoir utiliser une espèce de
ronde divine qui sera votre principal
moyen d'interagir avec le monde voilà
donc ça c'est la théorie maintenant le
problème c'est que Pac-Man a ce qui
s'appelle en terme médical un trouble de
laattention Sévère je veux dire il peut
pas s'empêcher de regarder le moindre
truc sur son chemin regardez-le la Sorci
je dois la tuer ah [ __ ] ce coupci
c'est la bataille finale l'ultime
affrontement entre le bonjour La Vache
bref laffonde vous permettra donc
d'éviter les obstacles sur le chemin par
exemple d'éviter de vous faire engueuler
comme une merde par le fermier sans
raison et d'ailleurs peut-être que vous
l'avez remarqué maintenant mais mon
Pacman a l'air déprimé c'est parce que
l'élément numéro 1 de ce jeu c'est la
gestion du moral de Pac-Man alors c'est
un petit peu rigolo parce que Pacman
dans ce jeu il est bipolaire et
dépressif mais au final le jeu lui-même
est aussi fun que mec bipolaire et
dépressif le moindre truc va l'éner ou
le déprimer vous regardez une falaise un
peu trop haute il a envie de se tailler
les veines vous réussissez pas à choper
votre coca alors là on va aller [ __ ]
des m et quand votre Pacman est énervé
il commence à faire des actions
incontrôlables je contrôle rien là mais
que quelqu arrête [ __ ] c'est devenu
une racaille arrête et ça va très loin
très vite il suffit qu'il lui arrive de
pauvre merde sur le trajet et il va
passer de la colère à l'angoisse à la
dépression en moins de 2
minutes et par contre quand votre Pacman
est déprimé là c'est terminé il nécoute
plus
rien est-ce que je viens de voir Pacman
se suicider après avoir agressé des gens
dans la rue mais pourquoi je veux dire
Pacman c'est une boule jaune qui mange
des ronds il y a pas plus Liss au niveau
du caractère comme hér je vidéo en ce
moment on travaille sur l'adaptation de
Pong on B sur le caractère des
personnage ch Nations Unies en tant que
bar pong je suis là pour trouver un
moyen de barrer la route au
terrorisme d'ailleurs des fois j'ai même
pas besoin d'avoir réellement des
problèmes sur il se met juste à déprimer
en ne réussissant pas certaines actions
et je vais sauter pardessus le trop j''y
arrive pas je suis une merde en fait il
faut un peu imaginer ce jeu comme une
sorte de point and click cruel en soit
on est assez proche du concept du jeu
Alex kid in hightech World tu pouvais
crever sur un peu n'importe quoi sauf
que là c'est pas trois ou quatre objets
c'est des centaines d'objets qui peuvent
te tuer ou te rendre dépressif et là où
ça pêche c'est que pour avancer dans le
jeu vous devez cliquer sur un peu tous
les objets que vous croisez pour voir si
c'est le bon choix le choix qui te fera
avancer dans l'aventure mais certains
item ne peuvent être activés que si
Pac-Man a un bon moral VI par exemple là
je dois grimper à cette corde mais mon
Pac-Man lui il veut juste se tailler les
veines du coup ben il y arrive pas il se
laisse glisser lamentablement comme un
chemur en fin droit et comme il a pas
réussi à grimper à la corde il déprime
encore plus et comme il déprime encore
plus il arrive pas à grimper à la corde
et ainsi de suite bref vous avez compris
bah après je vais avouer quand même
qu'il est marrant de rigoler du malheur
et de la souffrance des autres c'est
vrai bref évidemment c'est pas la fin du
monde notre petite boule jaune peut
retrouver quand même la pêche et pour ça
il faut le faire interagir avec des
objets qui remonteront son moral par
exemple manger des pommes ça redonne le
moral c'est bon les pommes pour la santé
ou bien danser tout seul au milieu de la
rue il est midi et je suis complètement
fou il perd la boule bah après quand
vous êtes dans un endroit où il n'y a
aucun objet qui vous permet de remonter
votre moral il existe raccourci c'est de
manger une pack gomme normalement les
pack gommes servent uniquement quand
vous croisez des fantômes mais ça peut
faire aussi office d'antidépresseur
parce que j'ai appris à mes dépan que
plein d'objets dans ce jeu qui ont l'air
d'être des objets positifs sont en fait
des drogues
hallucinogènes on est d'accord qu'il est
défoncé là bref du coup une pack gomme
et le voilà de nouveau heureux et si
vous n'en avez plus ne vous inquiétez
pas il les fait pousser dans son
jardin [ __ ] de merde les pack Gom
c'est du cannabis en fait en fait cette
astuce là d'utiliser les pack gommes est
quasiment indispensable parce que des
fois vous allez vous retrouver bloquer
un endroit sans issue avec un Pacman
dépressif qui ne veut plus rien faire et
à ce moment-là il y a pas de solution à
part la pack Gom ouou le suicide je suis
un déchet et ma place est avec les
déchets par ailleurs le jeu n'est pas
uniquement qu'avec ce gameplay dans le
niveau 2 vous devrez aller chercher des
fleurs au sommet d'une montagne et pour
ça vous devrez utiliser un delta plan et
[ __ ] c'est dur cette merde plutôt que
de faire un passage standard où vous
contrôlez Pac-Man il faut lui tirer
dessus pour les faire descendre tu
m'étonnes qu'il soit dépressif plus bas
j'ai dit j'ai dit plus bas et c'est la
même technique pour certains obstacles
je veux dire par exemple ici je ne peux
pas passer ce gouffre Pacman a peur donc
la seule solution
il avait pas une méthode moins cruelle
pour interagir avec ce pauvre mec non en
fait plus le jeu se rapproche de la fin
moins ça a de logique là où le niveau 1
et 2 Te demandit des objectifs
relativement évidents et linéaires le
niveau 3 c'est baisons la logique et
faisons n'importe quoi vous devez
récupérer la guitare de bébé Pacman donc
pour cela il faut se promener en ville
avec un Pacman en mode heureux mais pas
trop quand même ce qui en fait un
connard je veux dire qu'il va aller
péter les ballons du marchand et
l'envoie sur le toit ensuite il faut
passer donc par les toits jusqu'au bout
pour AR devant ce garde dont il faut
deviner qu'en fait c'est les fantômes
déguisés en garde qu'il faut ensuite
buter pour récupérer la guitare mais
seulement après avoir essayé de faire
rentrer Pacman pour le faire se décaler
au centre du portail c'est pas que c'est
spécialement dur c'est la combinaison de
facteurs qui est frustrante parce que tu
vas passer ton temps à passer et
repasser devant la bonne solution mais
non désolé elle se déclenchera pas parce
que votre Pac-Man n'est pas assez énervé
ah et puis merde je veux dire c'est
complètement con en plus oh là là
j'arrive pas à résoudre cette énigme oui
mais avez-vous essayé de vous énerver
dessus
waouh c'est vrai que ça a marché oui car
la violence n'est pas une solution c'est
la solution cela dit la vraie horreur
évidemment ça va être le dernier niveau
les fantômes se répandent dans mropolis
et seul un vrai héros pourra sauver
le bref donc pour cela il faut parcourir
la ville en recherchant l'entre du
méchant mais là attention surprise dans
cette entre tu dois passer un portail
dans l'usine qui te demande plusieurs
cartes et cartes qu'évidemment il faut
ramasser à l'autre bout du
jeu du coup retour à l'autre bout du jeu
au niveau de la montagne où il faut
passer maintenant par un espèce de train
de la mine j'adore les niveaux de train
de la mine car c'est toujours des
moments fun dans les jeux vidéos n'a
jamais dit personne dans l'univers vous
ne pouvez faire que deux choses ici dire
à Pacman d'aller plus vite ou lui tirer
dessus pour le faire sauter évidemment
he qu tous les niveaux de train de la
mine de mon cul de tous les jeux c'est
rempli de piège à la con de [ __ ] allez
saute [ __ ]
sute saute saute mais non mais pourquoi
tu sautes vite là maintenant [ __ ]
c'est pas une question de réflexe parce
que c'est pas spécialement rapide c'est
juste que entre le délai de la fronde et
le délai de Pac-Man quand il saute faut
lui envoyer un [ __ ] de fax pour le
faire sauter ah et pour pas arranger ça
évidemment il y a les fantômes au milieu
et surtout il y a aucun [ __ ] de
Checkpoint et qu'est-ce que vous avez
contrôl les check point mais c'est vrai
je suis sympa si tu es blessé tu viens
chez moi tu te reposes tu repars demain
il y a pas de problème je suis le checkp
le check
point je déd cette récompense à toute
l'équipe
d'écriture qui a pas voulu être là
aujourd'hui ta gueule mais la petite
cerise sur le gros tas de merde c'est
que cette carte c'est évidemment un
fantôme qu'il l'a et que évidemment
j'arrive ici sans mes [ __ ] de pilules
de xanax pourquoi parce que je suis
obligé de les consommer comme des
[ __ ] de Tic Tac tout ça parce que Jo
la déprim pas foutu de faire 4 m sans
devoir composer le numéro vert de SOS
suicide alors tu te dis bon ça va il y a
une autre sortie suffit d'y aller en
passant par la sortie et de revenir
comme ça ça prend 3 minutes mais non
quand tu reviens mais la porte s
[Musique]
refermé d'ailleurs note que la fête
n'est pas finie parce qu' une
combinaison secrète à connaître aussi
pour ouvrir la porte vu qu'il y a 5
emplacements mais il a seulement TR
cartes alors comment on connait la
combinaison mystère et boule de gomme
la blague est valide bref j'ai fait tout
le jeu sans trouver la moindre
indication pour trouver la combinaison
j'en déduis donc qu'il faut la trouver
par hasard et sachant qu'en plus ça
prend en compte l'ordre dans lequel tu
mets les cartes je vous laisse calculer
combien de combinaisons possi ça fait
donc je suis allé chercher sur le net
pour la trouver ce qui nous ouvre le
chemin du boss final le cum
Monster le cum
le attends non c'est c'est un G c'est un
G le gum le gum Monster le gum Monster
non [ __ ] arrête de faire ça s'il te
plaît bref donc pour gagner il faut lui
tirer en boucle sur la tête pour que
Pacman puisse manger les fantômes avant
qu'il ne rajoute du du gum qui fait
grandir le monstre et ce combat est long
et dur merde c'est c'est horriblement
dur de réussir à viser la tête avec un
curseur dégueulasse à la manette et la
difficulté de la Fronde là qu'il faut
tout le temps bander merde mais
finalement au bout de plusieurs minutes
le gum Monster est battu et la sorcière
est vaincue
tu as avalé mon
monstre enfin bref le jeu nous dit qu'on
l' pas fini à 100 % mais on s'en
contentera hein grenier avait lâchement
abandonné comme il le fait souvent il se
leva et se dirigea furieux vert e oh tu
fais quoi là non mais lâche-moi mais e
oh non fais pas
ça non je plaisante je peux pas tomber
je suis une veuf Sébastien venait de
rentrer dans la pièce et se demandait
c'est quoi ce bordel de merde
e ça fait une paye tu deviens quoi oh
ben comme d'ab et toi comment ça va tu
veux qu'on aille boire un ver ouais
carrément allons-y ça fait plaisir de te
voir depuis le
lycée après c'est pas plus con que
l'histoire avec les Chinois ouais c'est
vrai renre un soleil il fait des bandes
dans le ciel c'est lu Pac-Man Pacman en
quelques secondes il peut faire le tour
du monde c'est lu Pac-Man Pac-Man il est
toujours de bonne humeur il a
raison ça porte bonheur